There have been numerous world-renowned prison
escapes spanning across the decades, but let's
take a look at the most ingenious ones, the
escapes that took the most planning, dedication
and outright bravery.
Choi Gap-bok
South Korean prisoner Choi Gap-bok escaped
by squeezing himself through the food slot
of his cell door, you know, the small slot
on every prison door?
Yes that's right, he actually contorted his
whole body through a hole only 15 centimetres
(6 inches) tall and 43 centimetres (17 inches)
wide.
Choi Gap-bok was 50 and in prison for burglary.
He had spent most of his life in prison and
regularly practiced yoga, which must have
aided his escape.
One night, before lights out, he asked the
prison guard for a special skin ointment,
which they gave to him.
I'm sure the guards didn't think he would
be using it to squeeze through a prison door.
Choi Gap-bok was only 5-foot-4-inches which
helped, but it's still a bloody impressive
feat no matter your size.
He squeezed his entire body through the hole
in only 30 seconds.
Unfortunately he was caught again only 6 days
later, and put into a cell with a smaller
food slot.
Frank Abagnale
Frank Abagnale, the infamous conman that Leo
DiCaprio played in the film "Catch Me If You
Can", had successfully impersonated pilots,
teachers, doctors and lawyers.
So blagging his way out of prison was nothing
short of a day's work.
Frank was imprisoned for 12 years for fraud.
He got a stroke of luck, when in 1971, the
U.S. marshal transporting him forgot his detention
commitment papers.
Frank took this opportunity to subtly drop
the hint to one of the guards that he might
actually be an undercover prison inspector,
disguised as an inmate, so the guards gave
him preferential treatment.
He then called his friend Jean Sebring, who
had been previously visited by the FBI agent
in charge of Frank's case.
The FBI agent, Joe Shea, had left his business
card with Jean.
Jean then pretended to be a magazine writer
reporting on prisons, to also get the business
card of a prison inspector.
She visited Frank Abagnale in prison, posing
as his fiancé and slipped him both business
cards.
Frank used the prison inspector's business
card to prove to his guards, that he was in
fact an undercover inspector.
He told the guards it was imperative he speak
to the FBI immediately.
Frank handed them the FBI agent's business
card, but of course Frank's friend Jean Sebring
had already doctored the card so it displayed
her number instead.
Jean picked up the phone, posing as the FBI.
Jean said she needed to meet with Frank right
outside the prison immediately.
The guards happily obliged, after all, they
didn't want to get on the wrong side of a
prison inspector and FBI agent.
The guards watched as Frank Abagnale walked
right out of the prison, to be collected by
Jean, and they both rode off into the sunset,
guilty as hell.
John Dillinger
John Dillinger had already escaped from another
prison in 1933 using smuggled in rifles.
So in 1934 when he was arrested again for
a bank heist he was placed in the Lake County
Jail, which was known as "escape-proof".
The jail was constantly guarded by an army
of policemen and National Guard.
Yet Dillinger still managed a daring escape,
by fashioning a bar of soap to look like a
gun.
He forced his way out of jail with his "soap-gun"
and cheekily stole the sheriff's Ford to make
his getaway.
But he was later caught by the FBI.
The Great Escape
No prison escape in history has every come
close to the complexity of "The Great Escape".
The escape was from Stalag Luft III, a German
prison in operation during World War II.
It took about one year and the efforts of
600 prisoners to dig 3 tunnels, which they
nicknamed "Tom", "Dick" and "Harry".
The tunnels were 30 feet deep and tunnelled
underneath the the main fence.
The tunnels required complex systems such
as wooden blocks for support, a series of
lamps and electrical wire, an air pump to
supply air to the prisoners who were digging
and a rail cart system to move the earth quicker.
The tunnels should of surfaced in a nearby
forest but they dug them a little short and
during the actual escape they surfaced in
plain view of the guards, consequently only
76 prisoners escaped.
All but 3 of the escapees where eventually
caught by the Nazis.
Colditz
The infamous World War II, German prisoner
of war camp, Colditz, was a castle situated
on a cliff overlooking the town of Colditz.
There were many attempted escapes from Colditz,
but the best planned of them all occurred
when two British pilots, Bill Goldfinch and
Jack Best planned to construct a two-man glider.
Jack and Bill constructed the glider, bit
by bit in the lower attic above the chapel.
The plan was to ride the glider from the roof
across the river Mulde.
The pair built a secret wall in the attic
to conceal the glider.
The glider was painstakingly constructed from
stolen pieces of wood such as bed slats and
floor boards.
The germans who ran the camp focused their
searches on tunnels, it never struck them
to search the attic for secret glider workshops.
The war ended and the camp was relieved by
the allies before Jack and Bill had a chance
to make their escape.
However Channel 4 made a replica of the glider
in a documentary about the escape called "Escape
from Colditz".
In the documentary the glider was flown successfully,
showing the escape would of likely been successful.